why spend hundreds of dollars on a Wi-Fi
6E router right here in front of me I
have two great Wi-Fi 6 routers the E6
and the E4 from our sponsor rayi who are
making their debut in the US market
after 20 years of solid experience in
the networking field in this video I'm
going to cover the setup specs features
and speeds of both of these routers the
E4 RI ax 3000 is probably the best value
router I've seen since it's only 100
bucks on Amazon with the coupon code and
after testing out the speed as I'll show
you in just a bit I'm extremely
surprised by the quality and reliability
for the price and then on the other hand
they have their E6 rayi
ax6000 which is $200 on Amazon with that
coupon code but it packs a bunch of
extra features and performance so let's
start off with this E6 this is
essentially a competitor to the TPL link
ax6000 which retails at a higher $250
price but the rayi E6 basically matches
the Crazy Fast 6,000 megabits per second
Dual Band Wi-Fi speeds using the 160
mahz Channel as well as packing in a 2.5
GBS per second W port for super fast
ethernet comparing the speeds between
both of them they're actually spot on
hitting the maximum speed that my cable
provider is giving me so you're getting
the same performance with the re E6
that's probably because it has powerful
processing packing a 2.0 GHz quad core
64-bit CPU and expanded coverage with
eight high performance antennas as well
as eight high power fem or front-end
modules giving you a strong Wi-Fi signal
throughout your large home getting into
Wi-Fi speed testing the network
bandwidth of my home from Comcast is a
little bit lower than 500 megabits per
second I tested the Wi-Fi speed in
various rooms in including my guest
bedroom kids bedroom my living room and
on the other end of the house by the
front door and I was maxing out my
internet speed basically everywhere
inside of my house which was actually
very impressive I even took it on my
outdoor concrete patio which usually has
worse coverage and it was able to give
me a solid 300 megabits per second which
was awesome it also it also comes with a
one button mesh which allows you to
click the button and instantly connect
more routers within your home which is
great and as far as the setup and
installation it was incredibly easy
especially thanks to the clearly stated
instructions that were very easy to
follow I simply downloaded the rayi
router app I made an account clicked the
add router button then selected the
router from the list of Wi-Fi signals it
automatically detected it and all I had
to do was create my own custom Wi-Fi
name and password as well as enabling
the additional game Wi-Fi signal and bam
it was done the app also gives you a ton
of information and settings you can
customize as well as enabling Auto
bandwidth control which prioritizes your
devices that are using high bandwidth
like for gaming and it actually has
multi-level game acceleration it has
Gear Up console boosters for optimizing
for gaming consoles and it also allows
you to enable the game Turbo feature
which improves the utilization of public
channels reduces the latency and
provides a faster web browsing
experience on the back of the router
there are four land ports with one of
them actually being the gaming land port
which will always prioritize the device
you have plugged into this port which is
honestly a great feature for gaming PCs
and speaking of gaming I use the game
Turbo feature and did a bit of online
multiplayer Call of Duty gaming in my
living room which is on the other floor
compared to the router and the
experience was Flawless just as you'd
expect with no reliability issues or lag
it just worked perfectly and on top of
all of that there are a bunch of
settings like openvpn ddns dual Wan
aggregation dual land aggregation static
routing and more so overall the ri E6
ax6000 is a great value for the
reliability and performance that you get
and the five-star Amazon review ratings
basically prove it now moving over to
the ray E4 ax 3000 this is the option
for those on a budget being only $100 on
Amazon with the coupon being less
expensive than the $130 TPL link
ax55 its competition while offering the
same 3,000 megabits per second Wi-Fi
speeds which surprisingly still maxed
out my Comcast provider speed of around
470 megabits per second on both I ran
the same speed test as before but this
time on my wife's iPhone 15 Pro
connected to the ray E4 and to my
surprise I got got the same results as
the E6 and basically every room so the
coverage was awesome the E6 has a dual
core processor with five High Gain
antennas and five high power fpms giving
you great range with a gigabit Wan port
and two extra land ports so it still has
powerful processing this router also
supports multi-level game acceleration
with auto bandwidth control gaming Wi-Fi
priority devices and the gear up console
booster and because of the price this is
also a great choice for smart home
management because of the great range
and reliability so to sum everything up
the E4 is a great budget router for
General use including for smart home
devices while the E6 is better for those
who have larger homes and for gamers as
well as those more serious about their
Wi-Fi needs so with that said don't
waste your money on Wi-Fi 6E routers
when ones like these from rayi give you
such high performance for your cash and
you can order both of them using the
links down in the description below
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video